you know and I feel great at 104
temperature I feel great okay so good I
just feel good I feel clear you know I
just am sweating and I feel better yeah
I just feel okay you know it's not a
it's not a big deal
June did you see the video that Tim
posted of him as the corona virus yeah
you guys see ya yeah it was good it's so
funny you know can we play along here
not get in trouble I'm sure right um
yeah I mean you're allowed I will allow
it thanks Dan I won't allow it
how great would it be if I went back I
called my P my life I'm like yoke file
file move against them right now get a
strike yeah you can play if they just
[ __ ] this over you know my brother text
me that's I felt my brother Tyson goes
it's rare and it is a hater yeah that's
where I laugh out loud he goes watch
this well yeah you know it's interesting
is like I didn't even know what the
video was gonna be and I just all I
wanted to say was a line at the end
where I wanted to say I wish I wish I
was AIDS and and so I just had that
costume made 4,000 bucks because I was
like whatever so I'm out of work so
really good costume designer who's done
a lot of shift like Netflix he's good he
did the Epstein temple oh they did a lot
of those costumes so he just made it and
then I was just and me and my producer
were just [ __ ] around we had no idea
and I ad-lib all the [ __ ] then he added
sit together play this but it was all in
minute 42 I'm so [ __ ] depressed wait
let me put fullscreen so [ __ ]
depressed
I [ __ ] hate my life my dad thinks I'm
a piece of [ __ ] I've never accomplished
anything because she's the [ __ ] CEO
Microsoft and I'm a dumb friends I want
to be friends with people where people
freaking out you know hard yeah they
were pointing your cousin it's ours
yeah my cousin SARS I'd love to meet
this old [ __ ] I will gates my mothers
are back you think your family's [ __ ]
up I wake up every day there's another
[ __ ] news story is not true
hi Corona I'm trying to help these
people they're [ __ ] stupid listen I
live in Fox what kind of [ __ ] up she
did I live in someone's ass
Candace Owens does even believe I'm real
let me catch that big let me catch that
[ __ ] into Whole Foods
I'll go right up your nose will not be
able to transmit me to human my dad's
yeah we're gonna we're gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna give you to every single
person that's what my dad wants to do
what's it put a little bit of me in an
eagle and give it to a million people
what do you think that does to my sense
of self I'm [ __ ] real deal you don't
even know how I'm gonna affect you
nobody knows I might like your body I
might not I'm going to some of these
bodies I'm like get me the [ __ ] is
they're gonna ask me what the [ __ ] I
want to do with my life I want to put
something I'll have a lifestyle brand
baby nobody's maybe [ __ ] tick-tock
nobody wants to all be the tick-tock
week over 19 no one wants that
so just [ __ ] alone all the time I
wish I was AIDS and it's Owen so car
credit retweeted it was like [ __ ]
hilarious she did good for her she could
take a joke yeah it was good for Candice
Owens both so funny yeah it was funny
was that you wrote did all that yourself
read live it I just you know my editor
just follows me around with a camera
hotel and I just say crazy [ __ ] and he's
really is I mean that's what we did with
Meghan McCain every video I've ever done
it's like I just sit down and I just
start ranting he puts the camera on me
and then he just chops it up really good
now I'll make a suggestion here and
there but he's really good at like going
like this is the sequence of it this is
how it's gonna work
yeah in the hell you guys shut that help
for how many offers real sight for a
while an hour and a half but you know it
was we had an hour of footage if you got
down to a minute 30 like there's a lot
of footage and there's a lot of [ __ ]
footage of just me walking by things
like is it funny to walk by a certain
thing be Nolan [ __ ]
yeah all of that stuff then we just make
we've got them down to a science now
where we make it very quickly is anyone
upset no everyone's over a [ __ ]
everyone's thought it was funny right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]